[Music]
here with the owner of the first food
truck devoted entirely to what i call
nature's candy bacon
this man is a genius please welcome
jerry crowley from the lardon food truck
[Applause]
i love the smell of bacon i love the
sound of bacon cooking i love all things
bacon is this true that everything you
sell has bacon in it everything has
bacon in it conan it's bacon-centric so
everything there's if you come here
you're gonna have bacon if you like it
or not okay well that's
a weird thing to say
i wouldn't put that in your sales pitch
how did you come up with the idea to do
this well my wife heather and i were
just you know hanging out drinking
margaritas and talking about bacon
and i think it'd be a great idea to have
a restaurant all great ideas are thought
of
and that's it i mean then we bought it
or we you know started a food truck
because we're gonna board a restaurant
and uh so this is a truck you drive
around and you serve food that's just
jammed with bacon yes and made of bacon
everything okay uh now is it regular
bacon is it special bacon is it pork
bacon what are we talking about here
there's all different types of we use
the real bacon we use that skinny like
junky bacon that you get like over at
like a fast food place this is thick cut
bacon it's almost like a pork chop it's
so medium thick so you really get your
your money's worth with this bacon and
uh yeah it's not like this off the store
you know off-the-shelf type of bacon
it's just really good bacon there's you
know pepper bacon and duck bacon and
wild boar big different types you know
how much bacon do you eat a week
uh you know on the truck i can get to
like four pounds a week
are you worried at all about your health
i mean that's no no no there's you know
there's bigger things to worry about
than you're in your health
no
there is right i mean no
no don't applaud that idea that's
exactly wrong
health is the most important thing so so
you eat four to five pounds of bacon a
week have you had your arteries checked
no i have not no
so you could just go at any time right
now is that
you know if i did at least i went out
eating what i want to eat when i wanted
to eat it so i like that idea that's a
great
yeah
they started channing usa
uh okay now do you believe bacon has any
healthy properties are you one of those
guys that tries to say oh there's some
actually some good things about bacon
well yeah i mean like i was like there's
a few things like you feel good about
eating it but yeah i met this diabetic
guy at a party and he told me that
something with bacon is good for your
like pancreas so i mean there's got to
be some things you've done thorough
studies that's uh
i met a guy at a party
who told me it's good for my pancreas
well good uh do you put brown sugar on
bacon that's one of my favorite things
to do yeah that's candy bacon and not i
i don't eat candy bacon i mean but you
can
but my kids do they have a sweet tooth
what do you call me a wuss because i
like a little sugar on my bacon no it's
good it's good you just said you like
bacon every single way and then the one
way i suggest you like no i wouldn't do
that no it is that one bad idea i'd
still eat it all right uh oh wait tell
me what are we going to make here
quickly because we we need to get into
this sure what we're going to do we're
going to make the bako taco it's a baked
shell taco pretty much it's a shell of
thick cut bacon filled with potatoes and
cheddar cheese so yeah right i mean
that's real stuff right there
this is fantastic so a taco show filled
with unhealthy things and then the taco
shell itself is made of bait exactly
yeah okay fantastic all right so what we
do let's grab some bacon real quick and
lay it down
okay
i oh you can grab it yeah we got some
extra don't worry okay i got some right
here all right go ahead and then you
just put them down six across okay
and what is this by the way there's a
bottle of liquor here
that is a bacon-infused bourbon
that we use to make our bacon and uh
bourbon uh syrup can you get a look at
that in there look at that there's just
fat floating in this bourbon
do you drink this i haven't tried that
yet no but i would
i'll do it
here we go
ready
good it's good
[Applause]
usa usa great that's great
i've never been more proud of my country
all right yeah so go ahead just lay
those down like that once you get them
all across now we're going to do the
weave this is very important everybody
okay
are you ready
this is very important pay attention it
is you have to weave it so you go over
under over under right leg this is this
is part of the structural integrity of
the bacco taco okay it's it's uh you
know if you don't do this right you're
only gonna have a bunch of strips of
bacon which is fine also so it's a
win-win
i love that even if you do it wrong
you're pretty much fine that's right